[Music]
what's going on reject nation we are
back at cinemark today
and we are going to watch a quiet place
part
two and there's supposed to be a q a
actually with john krasinski
afterwards that's right it's gonna be
all science privileges
anyway we are going to watch this today
and uh very excited about it
cinemark they actually have an option
where you can do a private watch party
for up to 20 people for only 149
which is a damn good deal and uh
yeah but we're gonna go see it right now
we're just a bunch of regular folk
normies but we're influencers
we should have just had the whole
theater to ourselves don't they know the
power of a youtuber
but i respect it i think they'll approve
this
pretty necessary thank you cinemark
excited if you're watching quiet please
nice to be back
i've heard this movie is amazing and i i
hear it's even tops the first one so
let's go into it
[Music]
just finished the movie it was [ __ ]
awesome
all right guys well yeah we just sat
through a q a front row
and uh because john krasinski answered
our
question first out of the social media
round
um it's the best movie ever it's like
the most perfect movie i've never seen a
movie
it's the the greatest thing in the world
i'm gonna throw away my movie collection
and buy
all copies of a quiet place too this is
uncomfortable i don't know how john
campbell does this all the damn time
it's very uncomfortable i don't want to
spoil it for that we've been back to the
theaters a few times
and i don't mean this by any hyperbole
in any any way we've been back to the
theaters a few times by this point
and going back to this one
was like okay i really missed the
theaters
like we've we've seen a few movies now
i said it not long ago in some other
video where i was like honestly i've
kind of adjusted just watching new
movies at home i'm not i don't i don't
miss the theaters as much as i
once did but being back here um and
especially with the
insane like they double this should like
this has to get an oscar for sound
design because so much of the
storytelling and
the shifting of povs and perspectives
all comes down to that
and while i don't think it's a perfect
movie i still think it's
probably a better movie in my opinion i
think it's a little better what
would you think well yeah i mean it
flows really naturally i thought out of
the first movie
and it does a lot to both add context
but also just really continue honing in
on the characters and the anguish that
they're going through in the situation
there are a lot of very
tactile stakes and whatnot and so yeah
there are times where
you know you can tell something now john
starts talking the horn starts going off
i'm like a
perfect timing on my wrap up you know
yeah like these obstacles that they have
to go through in this world feel very
lived in
and even if you can tell that oh this
thing's gonna factor in later and i can
probably tell how
every time something comes up the
tension is there and yes
just the sensory experience of the sound
and the way you're cutting in and out of
perspectives especially
uh with millicent i'm forgetting her
last name right now but yeah the
the the the hearing girl yes the
daughter uh like she
carries the movie in a lot of ways but
everyone else is also
really good and stand out in their
performances too killian murphy
is incredible kelly murphy's really the
lead of this movie
after after millis and simmons yeah i
remember the first quiet place kind of
gets compared tonally and stylistically
to
the last of us i'm not going to give
anything away
but especially this one i was like i'm
really getting some blasphemous vibes so
like
like in so many ways you know it's like
that's joel that's ellie those are
clickers
these are the kind of humans who are in
the last of us there's a lot of things
in here that were remind and as a guy
who's a huge fan of the last of us
uh that's not a complaint at all on my
end if anything
the one little kind of criticism that i
kind of have with the movie is
it does have this sort of shift over
time where it slowly starts just
becoming
killian murphy and what's her name the
actress's name melissa simmons
millis and simmons it's it's hard to
come in their movie okay it's hard not
to get the [ __ ] away you have like kind
of two plots you're focusing on in this
movie there are points in which you're
cutting around to a lot of people in
different places
and then the way how nolan is pretty
good christopher nolan's really good
yeah that's the only one you guys know
but the way christopher nolan
is really good at cutting around
multiple events
kind of like this interesting montage
and cutting between parallel times and
watching the different scenes mirror
each other
and watching them fold like i really
feel like john krasinski mastered his
editing game
and his structure game especially
everything on a technical standpoint is
just so much more elevated
however there were times where i was
like oh yeah emily blunts in this movie
like there were times where i would kind
of for forget and i thought this would
be
more her movie and that's just sort of
from an expectation level that being
said
killian murphy is awesome in this movie
he's terrific and the relationship
between noah goop and millis and simmons
really does
shine like you know in the first movie i
feel like especially the sun no ajoops
character does get kind of a bump up in
this movie and something to overcome and
yeah i thought they used everybody
nicely still
and i think it's pretty cool how you
have like
so much of the awareness is like john
krasinski directed this and
emily blunt his wife stars in this and
sometimes the behind the scenes of that
i think if you're kind of aware of that
when you go in so i think it's pretty
cool that
it dawned on me halfway through it's
neat that they just kind of let everyone
else be the star of this movie the kids
yeah it's like due to the circumstances
but it really does feel like they are
passing the story along to
the two kids like it doesn't have to be
about us you know and i think that's
pretty neat
yeah uh how they how they let that be
embodied there are some real tense
moments some scary moments for sure it's
the moments where
you can just feel everyone in the
theater going
yeah like oh no yeah sometimes the
deaths in the film were a little bit
like
i know what's going to happen right here
uh it's going to happen yeah it's like
that was a little bit
predictable but at the same time i think
it's more powerful than the price for
some reason i thought this was more
powerful
everything is still pulled together
really well by character and story and
all the important stuff and i i think
too
maybe compared to the first one this is
a more patient movie too it's very
deliberate
there's definitely tension there's
definitely some jumps and stuff like
that and some monster mayhem but it
as a film uh is pretty patient pretty
deliberate and it definitely takes its
time and it's
kind of a laconic movie like there's a
lot of stuff that's just spent studying
the actors performances it's very
intimate you know
all right so as i'm doing like a quick
chop on this i was looking at myself
going there was something i was thinking
about here
and i remembered what it was and i
didn't know how to
properly phrase it without giving any
spoilers away
the group that we were with we all did
share this criticism about the film
early on in the in the movie there's
this line it's very
on the film this line that's stated
about the humans that inhabit this world
now they're not worth
saving so you know eventually you're
gonna see these
the humans that they're referring to now
in the moments with
those humans initially it was a
kind of goofy a little silly and overall
like the movie doesn't really
do much expansion or really flesh it out
all that much
john cecinski did say they are already
working on a part three he said this
during the q
a even though initially like we all kind
of the group of our group kind of had a
little bit of a chuckle when they first
showed up and and
how some of the execution of them was
done i can't say like the whole thing
about them
is faulty because there's actually some
really gripping suspenseful elements to
them as well
yeah i mean i feel like we would i would
want to point that out that it is a
little
silly at first i think the ending is
very poetic without going in any
spoilers at all when it was wrapping up
i got a little missed the eye to when uh
when you close the sky beam yeah and
then all the healings go away yeah
yeah they broadcast the drill signals
into the galaxy
but the way how the ending sequence
unfolds it's a great
visual storytelling that i would love
like the one real spoiler thing i would
love to go into
of like why it hit me so much in that
moment of like damn that is
that is a beautiful journey they just
told right there
honestly um i liked more than the first
one
and even though sometimes i would be
like oh yeah emily blunts in this uh
i still thought that when she was there
she's great and uh the sequences were
intense bring on part three yeah more
jaimon hansu
watch it in the theaters russian theater
seriously that that was the first that
was the first movie a long time was like
more than more than godzilla i need to
watch
everyone around you wrapped in silence
yeah
it's in a mark private screen deal with
your friends especially if you don't
want to hear people like aaron going
through his popcorn and stuff
yeah just rumbling you know because like
i was like a one popcorn kind of guy
and aaron was just like
he poured it out on top of his head at
one point and he started
smearing it all out i was like so
obnoxious he put some mentos into a coke
and just let it scream
dude quiet place too all right guys
well subscribe hit that bell like
whatever it feels weird to do this there
are people who are looking over at us
we'll see you guys
[Music]